since the false cries of racism and all
that stuff's not working what do you got
to do you got to bring back covid it's
back baby and fouchy who took about two
months off from being on tv he got uh
covered while he was taking some time
off even though he's twice vaxxed and
double boosted and god knows what else
they're injecting him with probably some
of the same cocktail that keeps biden
awake uh fauci is suddenly back uh and
that he dares even show his face is just
beyond imagination and he is now going
on television saying if only they had
pushed for more restrictions it wouldn't
have got this bad we know now
two and a half years later
that anywhere from 50 to 60 percent
of the transmission occur from someone
without symptoms either someone who
never will get symptoms
or someone who is in the pre-symptomatic
stage
had we known that then
the insidious nature of spread in the
community would have been much more of
an alarm and there would have been much
much more
stringent
uh restrictions in the sense of very
very heavy encouraging people to wear
masks
physical distancing or what have you
i don't know what to call the guy beyond
an authoritarian psychopath what else
could you possibly say now first off
that he didn't know they didn't know
back then that asymptomatic people were
spreading coping now first off if you're
asymptomatic
you're feeling pretty good so if you
have covet and you're asymptomatic who
cares
who cares a test comes back and it goes
oh you got covert and you're going well
i feel pretty good
i'm gonna go continue with my life and
many people got covered and felt
completely fine so that's number one now
i suppose yes you could be asymptomatic
and spread it to someone who could catch
it okay fine just like anything else you
might have a cough or the flu or
something like that and walk into a
store and get someone sick it's part of
life right and we have immune systems
for this reason humans and their bodies
blood cells and things of that nature
immunity and then you know contacting
with the real world and you know [ __ ]
gonna happen that's kind of that's kind
of how it works the idea that he says
that whether it was about
asymptomatic people or not that he in
retrospect they should have done more
stringent lockdowns more masking and
everything else they fired doctors they
fired nurses they fired it doesn't
matter what your job was all of us are
essential
i know i'm a crazy radical right-wing
extremist i believe all humans are
essential and they fired the not only
the people that they first deemed
non-essential but then they fired the
people that they were deeming essential
when those essential people didn't want
to get their experimental uh injection
which of course turned out not to work
as promised and some people are saying
now it doesn't even work at all and is
actually making people more uh more
basically uh susceptible to covid okay
so
the idea that he could possibly look
back he should be so shamed this man
should be so shamed and he is the
highest paid person in the federal
government he makes about
420 grand a year working for the federal
government and that he basically says no
we should have done more
we should have done more and it's not
just that we should have done more back
then uh he wants to bring back masks and
the rest of it look at this who are in a
zone or a or a or a county state or a
city that has a very high
level of dynamic of viral circulation
the cdc would recommend strongly
that you wear a mask in a congregate
indoor setting
and that would include schools places of
work
anything that
brings people together in a closed
uh environment
that is good
public health practice
okay
now
if you are elderly or immunocompromised
or all this stuff and you guys know this
everyone knows this already right
everyone knows this then you should take
whatever precautions you see fit if
that's avoiding crowds if that's wearing
a mask whatever the idea that the cdc
would still be pushing all of this stuff
that he dare goes out there as a
representative technically i guess he
works at the nih but he talks about what
cdc guidance is that he dares go out
there and still two and a half years
later is telling people to socially
distance and wear masks and get the
vaccines and all those things it's like
man you should have been fired you
should if all of the [ __ ] that you told
us for two and a half years work then we
wouldn't be in this situation would be
would we unless call me crazy you guys
want a perpetual
uh crisis